in a rare bit of good news in the year
of our lord 2020 i o interactive
developers of the much-loved hitman
franchise have acquired the most coveted
license in gaming
the license to kill we don't yet know
anything about io's plans for the james
bond franchise or even when it will
arrive
but that won't stop a bit of baseless
speculation on our part so
hop into our figurative aston martin and
let us drive you through the top double
07
things we want to see from the next bond
game
did you get it double 07 like
you get it oh pipe down double seven if
there's one thing that i o interactive
mastered with its recent reboot of the
hitman franchise
it was offering the flexibility to let
the player tackle any mission
however they wish as everyone's favorite
follicly challenged blowfeld look alike
you're free to charge through the front
door or guns blazing
or take a more subtle approach by
climbing drain pipes picking locks
and disguising yourself as an
inconspicuous waiter engineer
foot soldier mascot or a runway model
and generally sneak about unnoticed it's
easy to see how this could translate to
a bond game and it may go a long way
toward illustrating why io has bagged
the bond license
looking back through the annals of
double 07 history we see bond taking
many different approaches in order to
complete his missions
he even uses agent 47 signature wa 2000
in the living daylights
this open-ended mission structure is
something that's rarely replicated in
the bond games however with the notable
exception of the brilliant
the exchange mission in 07 nightfire
which saw bond tasked with infiltrating
a party in a castle
and allowed for a number of different
routes and tactics
though 47's main occupation is murder
io has previous with less violent
espionage thrills tasking players with
destroying a virus in sapienza
or hacking into computers in the new
york bank mission
and it's hard to imagine a greater
thriller's 007 than sneaking in and out
of some kind of top secret volcano base
to steal some important spectrophiles
without anyone even knowing you were
there of course if it's anything like
the movies it will more likely end up
with capture
torture escape and a load of commando
lads abseiling through the ceiling
but what would an open mission structure
be without the opportunity to kit your
super spy out with all manner of
exploding stationary
or a plaster cast rocket launcher
hitman has plenty of fun gadgets to play
around with and many of them venture
into the bondy mould
exploding rubber duck anybody
so this is the perfect opportunity for
io to dig through the q
branch archives and uncover some gadgety
gems
it would also work perfectly with the
replayable multi-strand mission
structure io games are known for
imagine seeing a locked event shaft on
your first run through and coming back
equipped with a laser watch to open up
another potential opportunity for
stealth
or for a less subtle option having a go
on that profoundly dangerous looking
bagpipe flamethrower they have in the
world is not enough
[Music]
what are they even going to use that for
admittedly it's easy to think of the
over-the-top gadgets but the cold war
origins of the bond franchise do
offer up some tantalising opportunities
for more realistic espionage too
be it forging documents planting
listening devices
or taking secret photos of clandestine
meetings
but you won't find us complaining if you
get to sneak into a smurf base in a
crocodile submersible either
i don't believe we've had the pleasure
mr um reaper
tobias reaper while the similarities
between agents 47 and 97
are clear we hope io don't lean too hard
into them after all what would a bond
game be without
huge explosions car chases jet packs
little
helicopter thingies and hidden ejector
seats
a bomb game needs to make you feel like
bond and more often than not bond is
doing something bombastic
so we hope that the game makes the most
of that plus it's hard to imagine 47
playing blackjack necking a martini or
someone named ivonna poker while his
friends and colleagues look on in horror
with some kind of heat sensitive
satellite camera from the safety of mi6
headquarters
everyone has a favorite bond whether
it's the pissed off wrecking ball energy
of daniel craig's bond
or the campy embarrassing uncle vibes of
roger moore's bond
with no time to die set to be craig's
final outing as double 07
and his replacement yet to be announced
what better opportunity to let the
player choose the kind of bond they want
to be
maybe you could be a menacing timothy
dalton-esque cold-blooded killer a
gadget obsessive who'd rather not get
their hands dirty
or even the kind of bond who looks
straight down the camera lens to deliver
quips
this never happened to the other fella
with the new game tip to be an origin
story the timing for a player driven
reimagining of the world's most famous
spy couldn't be better
so fingers crossed will get the
flexibility to decide exactly the kind
of spy
bond gets to be for all its gameplay
innovations the hitman franchise has
never had a particularly compelling
story with its pulpy
sci-fi leaning clone dramas and
confusing global conspiracies
on the other hand with the bond
franchise io has a wealth of ian fleming
stories to draw upon
many of which have never previously been
adapted as well as the more recent
continuation of the franchise by writers
such as anthony horowitz
it's not as if every bond story is a
masterpiece but at least they tend to
follow a certain mostly satisfying
trajectory
of investigation espionage and action
with plenty of twists and turns along
the way
however with io's bond there's an
opportunity to marry the simple but
satisfying plot staples of the double 07
franchise
with a new reactive story based on the
open-ended gameplay of the missions
imagine if the decisions you took in
missions impacted the way the story
plays out
perhaps taking out a major henchman or
preventing an arms delivery in
early missions could make later missions
easier or change the course of the story
entirely maybe it's too much to ask for
from a licensed game but such a system
would suit io's ponchon for replayable
missions
and offer players the chance to really
make the story their own
maybe it's just me but for all of
diana's detailed briefings i rarely
think of hitman's targets as
anything more than a bad person who
needs killing the exception to this is
actually sean bean's mark faber aka the
undying
an elusive target who borrows much from
bean's own acting career
including from his memorable turn as
goldeneye's turncoat 006
alec trevelyan for me a good villain
goes an
awfully long way to helping a bond story
feel better than the sum of its parts
even some of my least favorite bond
films have great villains like
max zorin of a view to a kill or messes
winton kid from diamonds are forever
and if io manages to write a compelling
bad guy it's halfway to a good bond game
already
pathetic but of course there's no sense
in having a good villain
if bond can't off them in some kind of
iconic fashion
and if io can draw on their experience
with hitman
then this should be no problem please
give me bubbling radioactive pools of
water
give me shark inflating pellets give me
terrifying chainsaw torpedoes
james bond in space i mean why not eh
moonraker is definitely one of the most
outlandish bond films but i say why not
lean into the fun
and jet off into outer space it's not as
if 47 is likely to be branching out into
extraterrestrial contracts any time soon
and imagine the fun
io could have designing a mission on a
bad guy's secret space station
venting villains out into the void or
turning artificial gravity systems off
okay so it's a long shot but as the kids
say you only live twice oh for god's
sake i'm
so sorry so there you have it our top
seven
things we want from the upcoming io
interactive bond game
but i'm sure you have other ideas so let
me know below
in the comments do you expect me to talk
no mr bond i expect you to like
and subscribe ah i could do this all day
you